all right welcome back to part 22 I
think it is I don't remember
quitting here actually it's pretty weird
I have a friend of mine over at my house
at the moment so if you hear any
background noise that's probably him
he's playing well so he tends to scream
a lot I don't know and I shed a little
bit I didn't realize what I was supposed
to do so I looked it up I know
alright here we go
I want this go down
Oh stuck sorry that was my escape
jump and jump
Sisson what the hell is on me he waited
for his eyes to adjust to the darkness
but no shape or contour appeared I'm
allowed
I am so scared right now oh this is nice
that's a creep at all
I stopped using my land and ever since I
increase the gamma I don't know why
spring yes you didn't use me to control
the water in the drain sewers to some
extent also it can be used for all sorts
of purposes like the drinking here well
there too but mostly to run different
machines
sir
ah I don't trust water since that water
part I really don't want to gain this
water go go go go go alright okay this
is definitely a puzzle part
what was that finger it's on
yeah let's definitely someone
tells this faint murmur it goes through
Lola what
kua squeeze through
oh sweet
ou can jump someone
and I'm so used to there being a monster
in there water and we should just
[ __ ] roc-a-fella no denying that
Aleksandr puts a lot of faith into what
I can only describe as merrily [ __ ] I'm
not surprised
even while travelling across Europe I
assumed I would have to embrace the
supernatural god damn it and life I
notice I do everything in my power to
stay focused
I'm not dwell sir those my escape my own
down I should turn that off Alexander
woke me up earlier and told me it was
time it turns out that Alexander is a
true renaissance man paralleled only by
DaVinci I'm sure he heard me turning up
that rooms fitted a specific research
such as Anatomy studies alchemy and
botany the crown of brennenburg must be
the inner sanctum a most hallowed ground
where we shall attempt to permanently
banish all
shadow I'm allowed was through this that
was not a good idea
I regret that immediately oh my god oh
oh my son I'm doing all right
what did I do redirect sewer water I
don't know why did I even do that
oh no no I wanna I don't want to take
tho oh geez I don't want to do this
okay up Danielle
did I do that
don't trust water
I really don't
all right already lit up you know that
means
although am I supposed to do this throw
my hammer right nope their work then
think it would oh maybe I can just
oh I see it now
let's jump
yes I didn't think that would work oh I
gotta get to other side first though
stupid
all right I have no idea what the [ __ ]
I'm doing
ah got that
what
whoop and it would I can direct it back
no it's stuck now goddamnit
whoa
that actually hurt me it's all good
I was so good there shake that out oh
there it was king from there I came from
here
hmm
hello little fishy uh-oh
I'm gonna call you peep you
all right oh I missed this
all right
I guess I got a Dutch these oh whoa all
right we're good
dodge the lethal steam there we go and
that [ __ ] off good
head of a hair redirect sewer water why
not eight boulders 1839 I could never be
certain and
that I was on the right panel using my
orb Alexander managed to channel its
power unto us on my loud
inner sanctum flared with blue fiery
light and I could feel the same things I
felt in the dark chamber in Algeria it
was like standing in a mad world pool of
impressions was terrifying
but Alexander kept calm and wielded
strange tools of science quite order to
tame the storm suddenly the blue light
was stained by strains of red and the
walls burst with pulsating tissue
resonating with the scene his sin and
before Ananda quickly covered the oven
some cloth and the unspeakable thing
vanished
apparently the orbs shadow is closer
than Alexander thought he said I should
prepare for a warding ritual tomorrow
I'm not sure what he expects but I have
a back so do I
how do I had a bad feeling for a long
time now let's redirect the water again
why does it have to be creepy music just
because I do that god damn it
not today
all right good so far
so let's head where the lost oh oh oh oh
oh whoa where the [ __ ] did I come from
I want to go in the water again
what the hell was that is it a new
monster I think two is enough okay I'm
gonna run for it run run run oh okay I
think he's gone
I just wanted to piss make my pass bits
or something at around it's a bridge
down no I must put supposed to make the
bridge go down
holy [ __ ] that actually worked I was
just about to say all my [ __ ] ideas
never works but this one actually worked
well
all right what am I supposed to go
though
uh-oh I can walk here awesome
redirects water why the [ __ ] not
oh you should have read this first
valleys are busy preparing for the rich
why
this expected
but should then
it must've been yesterday Alexander what
if in a
I realize that recent polls
this request
I don't get what the arm does something
Oh
what did I do exactly
alright let's head back
that surely changed something at least
[ __ ]
Oh goddamnit jump you [ __ ] oh oh oh
get up get up get up Danielle [ __ ]
you're so slow what is that noise
I don't want to go over there but I know
I have to let's just take it nice and
slow
there
I heard
good
The Voice went silent how does that mean
the hell
see momenta yay
yeah sure
thanks man
got some coke all right
god I hate this creepy music
where am I supposed to go
already been here
sarted I will steam
sorry that was steamed again I should
look out yeah yeah yeah
still stuck did I miss something part
I want to walk in the water I hate fat
jump and jump and jump
crystal-clear honor